bien mesdames messieurs une fois encore
notre pays a été frappé par une attaque
terroriste islamiste
une fois encore ce matin ce sont trois
de nos compatriotes qui sont tombées à
nice en cette basilique notre-dame de
nice est très clairement c'est la france
qui est attaqué au même moment vous
avions un site consulaires français qui
était attaquée en arabie saoudite à
djeddah au même moment des
interpellations sur notre territoire se
faisait je veux ici dira d'abord et
avant tout le soutien de la nation toute
entière aux catholiques de france et
d'ailleurs
après l'assassinât du père hamel à l'été
2016 c'est une nouvelle fois les
catholiques qui sont attaqués dans notre
pays menacés avant les fêtes de la
toussaint la nation toute entière se
tient à leurs côtés et se tiendra pour
que la religion puisse continuer de
s'exercer librement dans notre pays car
notre pays c'est cela ce sont nos
valeurs que chacun puisse croire ou ne
pas croire mais que chaque religion
puisse exercer
et donc aujourd'hui la nation toute
entière se tient aux côtés de nos
concitoyens catholique
le deuxième message que j'ai et pour la
ville de nice monsieur le maire pour les
niçoises et les niçois si durement
éprouvée par la folie terroristes et ce
terrorisme islamiste c'est la troisième
fois que le terrorisme frappe votre
ville vos habitants je sais le choc que
votre ville ressent avec elle tout le
pays et je crois le monde entier qui
nous regardent
là aussi je vous dis le soutien la
solidarité de toute la nation
si nous sommes attaqués
une fois encore c'est pour les valeurs
qui sont les nôtres pour notre goût de
la liberté pour cette possibilité sur
notre sol de croire librement et de ne
céder à aucun esprit de terreur et je le
dis avec beaucoup de clarté une fois
encore aujourd'hui nous ne céderons rien
ce matin nous avons décidé d'augmenter
la posture de vigilance partout en
france pour nous adapter à la menace
terroriste
j'ai décidé que nos militaires seront
dans les prochaines heures davantage
mobilisées et nous passerons la
mobilisation dans le cadre de
l'opération sentinelle de 3000 à 7000
militaires sur notre sol nous nous
mettrons ainsi en situation de protéger
tous les lieux de culte en particulier
bien évidemment les églises pour que la
toussaint puisse se dérouler dans des
conditions qui sont dues nous
protégerons aussi nos écoles pour la
rentrée qui vient
demain se tiendra un conseil de défense
nous acteront de nouvelles mesures dans
la continuité de ce que faisons depuis
plusieurs mois dans la continuité de ce
que j'avais annoncé lors du discours des
mureaux et de ce que nous avons ensuite
mise en oeuvre de manière permanente
je veux saluer la mobilisation de tout
le gouvernement est tout
particulièrement du ministre de
l'intérieur et du garde des sceaux qui
m'accompagne le procureur ricard aura
dans les prochaines heures à donner tous
les détails sur les faits de ce matin à
la fois sur déroulé des événements sur
l'auteur il ne m'appartient pas ici de
les commenter
simplement de dire notre détermination
absolue et que des actes continuerons de
suivre pour protéger tous nos
concitoyens pour répliquer
c'est donc un message de fermeté absolue
que je veux passer aujourd'hui
et enfin c'est également un message
d'unité
en france il n'ya qu'une communauté
c'est la communauté nationale et je veux
dire à tous nos concitoyens quelle que
soit leur religion qu'ils croient
d'ailleurs ou qu'il ne croit pas que
nous devons dans ces moments nous unir
et ne rien céder à l'esprit de division
je sais que tous nos concitoyens sont
aujourd'hui profondément choqué
bouleversée de ce qui vient une fois
encore de se passer donc j'appelle à
l'unité de tous
voilà le message que j'étais venue
passer aujourd'hui à nice et je sais
combien la ville le départ pourra
d'ailleurs ou qu'il ne croit pas que
nous devons dans ces moments nous unir
et ne rien céder à l'esprit de division
je sais que tous nos concitoyens sont
aujourd'hui profondément choqué
bouleversée de ce qui vient une fois
encore de se passer donc j'appelle à
l'unité de tous voilà le message que
j'étais venue passer aujourd'hui à nice
et je sais combien la ville le
département sont éprouvés j'étais à vos
côtés il ya quelques semaines à peine à
la suite des inondations soutien de la
nation à nice aux catholiques de france
fermeté et unité telle est la ligne que
nous devons suivre aujourd'hui que nous
continuerons de suivre demain je vous
remercie